hi in this module i'm going to talk
about laplace smoothing for guardian and
glance over
so let's review maximum likelihood
estimation
remember last time we had an example of
a two-variable
work a genre of a movie and the rating
of the movie where their joint
distribution is given by probability of
a genre times probability of rating
given
and now we don't know these parameters
but we want to estimate them from data
suppose we gather
five data points here
and the way that maximum likelihood
estimation works is by counting and
normalizing parameters here are
probability of g
and for that i'm going to count the
number of times
g
goes up
and normalize
and for
probability of r given g i'm going to
look at the number of times each of
these configurations shows up
and then i'm going to normalize
each one condition on the value
so if you look at these estimates you
might notice that there's something
funny going on here
so
the probability that these
parameters assigned to a rating of two
given that there's a comedy is zero it
doesn't show up in this row of this
table which means that it's zero
so do we really believe this
just because we didn't see an example of
a comedy being rated as a two are we
licensed to just give it a probably zero
well that would be very close my dead
so this is a case where maximum
likelihood has overfit
there's a very simple way to fix this
called laplace smoothing
and the idea is that we're just going to
add
a lambda
which is some positive value let's say
one to each count so let's do a maximum
likelihood with laplace movement
so training data is the same as before
and what we're going to do is for each
of these local distributions we're going
to preset pre-load a 1
labda more generally into this position
and now i'm going to go through the
training and count as usual so i add
three and i add two
and then i'm going to normalize
over these combined counts
and same with uh the probability of r
given
g for each of these
configurations so now i have to actually
instantiate all possible configurations
i'm going to load a one
into each of these counts
and then i'm going to look at my
training data
and i'm going to add two there's two d4s
one d5 one c1 and one c5
now given these counts i'm going to
normalize to get my probability limit
look at all the d's count them up
normalize i get
um some
of these here and look at all the case
rows where g c
i'm going to
sum in
so now
what we revisit our probability estimate
of r equals two given uh g equals c
this was zero before
but now it's uh
here that's one over seven which is
greater than zero
so now because we smooth these estimates
now we have a little bit more
probability on even
those outcomes that we've never seen
during training
the key idea behind maximum likelihood
laplace smoothing is follows
so we're going to go through each
distribution
and partial assignment
uh to
the parents of a node and the node
itself
and we're simply going to add lambda
to the count
now we do maximum likelihood estimation
as usual so we're going to go through
the training data and increment those
counts based on what we saw
and then we count and normalize and
that's it
so the interpretation that we can place
on the plot smoothing is it's like we
hallucinated
lambda occurrences of each local
assignment so sometimes these uh lambda
accounts are called pseudo counts
because they're not based on the data
they're kind of made up for virtual
counts
so you can think about pretending you
saw some examples before you saw data
and then do a maximum likelihood image
so
how
much
should lambda be how much smoothing
should we have and how does it interact
with the um there's two observations i
want to make first is that the more
you smooth which means that the more the
bigger the lambda is
the closer you're going to push the
probability estimates closer to the
uniform distribution so for example
if i just smooth with lambda equals
one-half
then and i observe only a d here then
the probabilities estimates are going to
be three quarters in one corner whereas
if i smooth with one then the
probabilities are going to be two-thirds
and one-third which is closer to
half-half
the second observation i want to make is
that no matter what you set lambda to
the data wins out in the end
so suppose we only see examples of
dramas
so suppose that we're smoothing with
lambda equals one and we saw only one
example of g equals
then again the problem estimates are
two-thirds and one-third
but suppose we keep on seeing dramas
over and over again so we see 998 of
them
and now if we account and
normalize then we get the probability
estimate as 0.999
uh
of drama which is much closer to
scene-only dramas
so to summarize
uh we
looked at laplace smoothing for avoiding
overfitting and estimating beijing
networks
and the key idea is that
we preload counts with a lambda
and then we're going to go to training
data and we add
counts based on our data and then we
normalize
so
the smoothing pulls us away
from zeros to the uniform distribution
but in the end
all the smoothing
gets washed out with more data
that's the end